according to a new study elderly women
who perform routine housework activities
such as cooking and washing dishes may
be at a reduced risk of heart disease
here to comment is my piece of [ __ ]
cousin mike who lives with our grandma
and doesn't contribute anything
hey what the
why'd you tell your whole audience i'm a
piece of [ __ ] cause you are a piece of
[ __ ] mike
living in grandma's basement for 12
years never helping out for [ __ ] yo
deadbeat
hey you for your information grandma
likes taking care of me and according to
a new study it's helping her maintain a
reduced risk of heart disease oh
[ __ ] you just found that out two
seconds ago grandma doesn't want to
spend her golden years
in your hot pockets dumbass
oh
how do you know maybe grandma loves
microwaving hot pockets oh yeah you
think she loves shoveling the wok too
though i don't know maybe you're such a
piece of [ __ ] stop calling me a piece of
[ __ ] on live tv it's not live you dumb
oh no fall hey grandma oh hello michael
i got your hot pocket here i hope you're
hungry oh thanks grandma
oh my is that amber hi grandma hello
amber what are you doing here oh just
catching up with cousin mike
isn't he sweet he's the sweetest
he really is okay i'm going to go back
upstairs you kids have fun
bye grandma
my piece of [ __ ] cousin mike everybody
grandma this is cool
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you